fresh off a remarkable non-playing
season in which uh he seems to have the
whole band back together with free
agency
through uh that looking glass and a
draft in the books
the general manager of the world
champion tampa bay buccaneers jason
light back here on the rich eisen show
how are you jason
i'm doing great how are you doing rich i
am doing better uh for
for you asking thank you for asking
how's life how's life for you jason like
how's everything life is uh pretty good
it was a
hectic off-season one of these days
gonna realize we won the super bowl so
[Laughter]
how did you um i guess how did you go
about it did you have like a list of
i'm gonna hit these people and i'm gonna
get them handled or how many plates were
you spinning
at once trying to resign everybody that
were free agents from your championship
team
well there are quite quite a few of us
here been in a lot of plates
doing this uh you know no one person can
do this on their own so i have a great
staff
um we didn't necessarily prioritize any
one over the other we kind of
prioritized every one of them
and everyone was unique every
negotiation and
just started i kind of felt like the
seinfeld episode as soon as we got one
done we'd ring the bell and uh
you know and have another one and mark
it up on the chalkboard so
it was uh finally we were finally able
to get through all of them i
at the time i didn't i didn't realize
that it hadn't been done
since whatever 1977. if i would have
known that then
i would have been a lot more stressed
about it but uh
once bruce made the proclamation at the
boat parade and then i
doubled down and said the same thing and
then i turned around i said oh no what
did i just do
saying that you could re-sign everybody
that you could get out of that i mean we
could resign everybody but
we were confident guys wanted to come
back great environment great head coach
great ownership
great quarterback we uh a lot of great
players so
it's it was uh it wasn't as it wasn't as
it was everything's a little bit
strenuous
getting through negotiations they're not
all easy but
uh at the end of the day everybody
wanted to be here so that's that's
exciting
so uh does that make you the lloyd braun
of general managers if i'm not mistaken
based on your analogy right there jason
did you
know who does that make the stanza's dad
is that aryans costanza's dad in the
garage
of the tampa bay yeah maybe you could
say that
although i i will still uh george's
dad's line of serenity now
[Laughter]
well you got it done jason you
definitely got it done
how much did brady play a role in
in all of this jason well
the fact that we were we extended him
we're able to you know give us some
relief on the cap
was big and the players
you know what tom brought to the
organization as the leader
uh you know is is priceless and
having him and bruce as our head coach
and quarterback
tandem both excellent leaders both very
unique
people and in in what they do the way
they do it is
it obviously played a huge role in these
guys wanting to come back and be a part
of it again
well i mean the reason why i asked this
too as well is
did did he make some calls to help the
band get back together here
to twist an arm pound a table
uh to you or twist an arm with uh one of
his teammates to
to to come back i think we were all
pretty much on the same page
bruce myself him on that we wanted to
bring
back as many as we could i don't know
what conversations he had
uh you know with with our players to be
honest with you
um i just knew at the beginning free
agency i said hey i'm going to do my
best to get everybody back
and that was really the last we talked
about it
and then your conversations with him um
personally jason i i i i really want to
dig into this as much as you're willing
to share
because i'm i'm sure you're aware that
there are
some other teams with first ballot hall
of fame quarterbacks who
might be having an issue with not having
a say and how uh
um in a roster is fashioned around them
and to their desires and they're all
pointing at your organization with you
and your quarterback and saying how come
we can't be more like them and uh
what what is your relationship with
brady do you
ask him what he's interested in does he
volunteer it like
what what is what is the the secret
sauce that goes in right here
jason it's it you know it's it's it's
it's a fair question but
we he came to our team
with because of the great coaching that
we have the great head coach and the
the great players and he wants to play
with great players
there's never been a conversation well
you better get this guy or
we don't want that guy or i've never
talked to him about the draft
bruce and i did mention to him leading
up to the draft that we might take the
quarterback just we would do that with
any
great quarterback but yet alone the goat
but
he's he had well i hate to sound cliche
but he trusted
uh in the plan that we wanted to bring
everybody back and there were really no
never any side conversations about
uh how far along are we with this guy
what should i do what can we do
uh move on from him he's not like that
he's a great leader
and um he's you know he's got the
players trust and
he trusts us and so there's really never
much of a conversation of you saying
well
you know who do you like because again i
i and i know this is a very touchy
subject and
and so i ask it gingerly but it just
seems that
you you've got a relationship and it all
worked out you won a championship you
you extended them
that is the envy of every over 35
goat quarterback for their franchises
and and it seems like you're
you're on cruise control in that respect
and that's why i'm trying to figure out
what the
two-way street might be here to you know
because he's got a window of opportunity
in his mind and you're addressing that
window of opportunity and it seems like
it's being dressed the manner in which
it makes him very happy and i'm
wondering how that works with your
relationship
jason i think he's i think he was very
happy just
with the players in the roster and the
coaches like i said
before and now with with any
great player like tom at that position
if we're thinking about signing uh
gio bernard for example i'll let him
know hey
thinking about signing geo bernard
little push might help he's like
i'm on it um love that kid you know
uh with leonard last year that that's
awesome i
love that he'd be a great addition i'll
help you out you and bruce out as much
as i can
so i think he likes the fact that we we
tell him you know who we're thinking of
signing every once in a while if it's
particularly if it's going to help him
at that you know on the offense so but
in terms of having this a meeting where
we go over the board and talk about all
of our plans uh
that's that's just not his style he's he
trusts us like i said
and then um when you had jason light gm
of the tampa buccaneers here on the rich
eisen show i'm gonna ask you the 64
million dollar question here
um when you talk to him about extending
was there a sense that this is the last
contract extension you're going to have
a conversation with him did he give you
any indication at all
how long none he wants to play yeah all
right you know i want to keep all those
conversations most from private but
no no inkling at all uh told him he
wants to play until he's 50 and
he's still playing and he feels like he
can still play he can play until he's
50.
so and then you mentioned you and bruce
did say
heads up um we might be taking a
quarterback in the draft
you did give him that heads up go yeah
gave him that heads up
okay just didn't he almost responded if
you i appreciate you letting me know you
didn't need to let me know but i
appreciate it and
whatever whatever we have to do to make
the team better so what do you say to
kyle trask welcome the team
there's uh there's your quarterback room
with the goat um
understand that you might have to take
his elbow during uh
a boat parade but other than that like
what do you what do you say to kyle
trask when you welcome to the team
jason well actually i had the chance to
talk to him a few times since and uh
told him he's got a great opportunity
with this you know plane behind
tom and blaine is a great uh mentor as
well and then
obviously this coaching staff um byron
and
clyde christensen and bruce and tom
moore
it's he's a great opportunity and i
think he's he's beyond excited about it
it's it's uh like i said i think it's a
great opportunity for a young
quarterback to come in
and see and see firsthand how how you
know
tom brady operates get ready for a game
zero pressure
zero pressure right i mean just like
zero pressure just learn what you can
learn
glean what you can glean and and just um
check tom out all you can i guess that
and then and
and then you point out i mean what a
hell of a coaching staff you have of all
the experience together
it seems to me that bruce is totally um
energized not like that that's ever been
a question but obviously with him coming
out of
retirement um that he seems
re-energized and is there any talk about
how how long he wants to
still be at it jason to you there
we really haven't had that talk in this
uh
in this business it's a year one year
seems like 10.
right so he i do i do agree with you he
he has felt never felt better never
looked better
and he is energized he's got it he's got
a great staff that
i won't say we're on cruise control
because he rides them um like any
good coach does but he has total trust
in his entire staff offense and defense
well he loves
leftwich i mean like he you know he
he hand-picked byron um
you know in many different ways from
being a player to being a coach and then
i know he was here
when he was you know out of the game and
in the booth at cbs at the time
literally sitting in the chair that's to
my right here
jason talking about how he was fearful
sometimes that he might have
a health episode on the sideline and he
would never come back
without somebody who he trusted to call
the place and that person is byron
leftwich
and i i mean he's beyond dynamite and
i'm wondering what you you think of him
long-term future for your franchise
as well well jason well we're we're in a
we're in a great position
where we have a lot of great coaches and
byron is one of them
todd bowles um harold goodwin
um we're we're stacked at our
coordinator position
so our special teams um
i think we're going to be a lot better
this year and we improved in a lot of
areas last year
so we've we've got a lot of great
coaches and we're focused on this year
right now but we do have a lot of
coaches i think that would
be uh great in the role of head coach in
the few minutes i have left with you
jason light gm tampa bay buccaneers what
is what is the
the i guess front burning issue on your
radar screen obviously we we heard you
know
tom did get on a call with the players
association
and pushed reportedly to use this moment
um to push back against uh the amount of
time that players are in quotes
required to be there or either not
mandatory but kind of made to feel that
way
uh are is there an issue with the bucks
getting you getting your players there
for bruce to get
their hands on i mean what what is
what's going on on that front
we're just going to have to see how it
plays out here of course we would like
to have as many players
the players that the less experienced
players
whether it's rookies or or first second
third year guys backups
at other positions to get them as
prepared as possible and you know
the the best way for that would for them
to get as much work in as possible
but we're just going to have to uh see
how it plays out
and our hands are tied right now
we'll we'll see what happens but we
we just want to make sure that our
players when they when we do report um
get ready for the season and training
camp and in july that they're in the
best possible shape that they can be in
so is there uh what what's on your radar
screen now
that you're you're post draft you've got
your undrafted free agents you've got
you know mandatory mini camps coming up
and
obviously um everything out like
literally what's on your radar screen of
concern for a general manager of a world
champion club
right now like i said that that
everybody's in great shape that we don't
have
a lot of injuries once we report in
for training camp and everybody's uh up
to speed the best that they can be
so we can hit the hit the ground running
and
where we left so where we left off last
year so
and and to be honest with you my my
what's on my radar
is is rookie mini camp coming up and
then
and then taking some time off with my
family for crying out loud for you
good for you um and last one for you
jason i mean i
i don't want to create a rift here um
and that's obviously a very
controversial way to start a question
but
i had bruce arians on the um nfl draft
coverage live
on nfl network he said he was the one
who threw the
uh lombardi trophy from one boat to the
next first
before brady were you did you witness
this is this is this true did he
flip the lamborghini i was on the boat
my family was on the boat with bruce and
saw him toss it over
come on i mean no it was a it was a two
foot toss okay
but still there was there was a moment
where the lombardi trophy was
aloft already um in the air
from one boat yeah you know and bruce
was more of a russian quarterback than a
throwing quarterback
so hold on a second so did he flip it
over tom moore to get it there is that
what he's doing i mean like
like walk walk me through like was it
brady's boat that he flipped it
too is that how that worked yeah it was
no it was a good toss i
didn't mean to take anything away from
bruce by saying he was more of a russian
quarterback but um
right it was pretty good it was more
like an option toss and um
like i said it was about two feet away
and it was uh it was done to perfection
it really wasn't a flip
okay very good and then last question on
it i could've said
i could understand exactly why memories
are hazy um
who caught it on brady's boat what did
tom catch it was it thrown from aryans
to brady
or was it that is where things get a
little hazy here
[Laughter]
understood understood and it's not
because you know it's been too long
since the boat ride
i could ask you that question with two
minutes after it happened it would have
been hazy at the time
so what you're saying jason you you
might be saying the right
okay very good i just want to be
accurate that's all i want hey jason
thanks for the time i always appreciate
it let's talk uh
during the summer and get a set for the
season enjoy seeing the schedule coming
out on wednesday
do you have a sense at all right now who
you think you're gonna be
opening the season against right now you
got an inkling what do you think i
i i really don't i don't have any sense
i just know
i'm sure it'll be a very good team that
we're going to have to get ready for and
it is a thursday it is a thursday night
though they're not going to do it on a
sunday you you're planning for the the
first thursday is that what that is
i the only inkling i have and it's not
because i have information but the only
inkling i have is that it would be a
thursday night but
you know that i could be wrong there as
well okay jason thanks for the call
truly appreciate it i hope you do get
that time with your family you deserve
it
thank you appreciate it they do thank
you excellent you got it that's jason
light everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here